going right
all right uh it's just uh 10 o'clock or
a little bit thereafter and so with that
we're going to open the uh
The Division III work session on
Behavioral Health
this is uh the only scheduled topic for
the day
so um so we're all yours who's who's
going to start us off
I did miss Fox Run Away
Chief LED I asked her a question she
fled oh there she is
well my mom always said something like
that
and I noticed she didn't drink a whole
lot of the water she had in front of her
either so
go ahead you can get started
are we live well can we check because we
should be live at this point
yes is the answer okay go ahead
uh good morning uh Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer of the Department of
Health and Human Services and I'm joined
here today with I'm Katya Fox I'm the
director of the division
Division and uh just to start off just
to orient everybody to the documents in
front of you as we did yesterday
um we have the the presentation uh that
Katya will be moving us through here the
and then we also have the
The Briefing book for the division for
Behavioral Health as well and in the
budget in the governor's recommended
budget the division for Behavioral
Health begins on page 1019 and with that
I will hand it over to Katya so we'll
come back to like 897. so you say we're
we're starting at page what
1019 yes we'll come back to that page
thank you
uh um we're excited to present this
information I know that we appeared in a
pre-meeting or a pre-budget session to
go over rapid response which will be
discussed as part of this presentation
um but that now I can give you a full
picture of the work that our division
does so
um just the first couple of slides
you'll see our shared vision
um and then on page three really this is
a um a visual that we've used in a
couple of different ways but they all
really tell the same story and they talk
about what our uh goal and our vision
and our actual objectives are in how
they are laid out with starting with
prevention going all the way to our
crisis in inpatient care so we have
Community Education which is at a
general level where
um uh population health approach as
you've heard from Trish Tilly about
where we do that about resources
awareness and
the skill building
um
programs
prevention in Early Education we have
Universal prevention again population
Health prevention and then selective
prevention for at-risk groups and then
some early intervention work that we'll
talk a little bit about later in the
presentation Outpatient Treatment I
think a lot of you know and are familiar
with that that's the office and Clinic
settings that we provide services
assessment and diagnosis consultation
treatment and Rehabilitation
so so I like this slide I like the the
the flow part of this yeah um so
um if if I were to want to draw on this
uh where I think it's the cans report or
the cans assessment you know where where
it might begin it may I think it may
begin potentially in every one of these
bubbles but it's meant to be an
integration tool between the bubbles I
think and then so and then also is is
there uh an I.T system or a combination
of I.T systems that that Connect the
Dots here yes
um so the latter there are a combination
of systems we have the data systems you
reference the cans assessment which is
in the children's
um for children's
um and Adolescence strengths assessment
um is For Children and adolescents yep
and then what
um what I T Systems then tie this
together I assume the closed loop
referral system when it goes live we'll
do this too yes
um that is one of the programs as well
as our event notification
their providers that's the sheriff and
I'm not going to answer his phone call
so they may hold me out any minutes
that is
um the event notification where a
provider can with permission and all of
the uh appropriate reviews can notify
another provider about an event that has
happened a change in status of an
individual referring to the closed loop
referral system
um there's closer referral but there's
also event notification oh okay they're
distinct okay and and I I'm going
through this because I think we've
talked about it tangentially over the
last couple of years but we have some
new people to division three and the
closed loop referral system was a huge
topic of conversation and event
notification is kind of a a simpler less
robust system right yes yep
so if you want to just tell us a little
bit about that and I'm sorry I'm
throwing you off your presentation right
away that's okay but I just I just think
that's a question seeing how how your
how your flow because this is really
this is really the challenge in New
Hampshire isn't it I mean within each of
these bubbles we it feels to me like
we've got
Noble answers and solutions but then
it's when we try to integrate this flow
where
a chain is only as strong as its weakest
link and and I just want to have
everyone understand how we how you how
we try to manage this
great so close loop referrals so that's
what we
in uh general terms it is care
coordination and it's a way to do that
through electronic health records and
through shared information among the
providers of an individual so if you
make a referral
to another program to address someone's
needs then there is a way to be able to
see all of the
efforts that have been made in all of
the steps and programs that that one
individual is accessing so you close a
loop by making sure that there's that
care coordination when someone is in
your care so you know that they did
follow up and they did take the next
step or that they didn't and there's a
way to interact and have that discussion
with that individual
so event notification as you said it's a
little bit simpler it's when an event
happens and it's a change so for example
um someone uh need is discharged from
New Hampshire hospital so that's an
event notification to the provider to
say hey the pro the individual that you
are serving did have the hospitalization
and now is returning to the community so
it's a way to notify of that event
specifically
those are the ones that are most often
thought of when we talk about the
individuals at the um at the provider
level we have our Data Systems
which is and I think perhaps Dave
weeders talked a little bit about those
but we have the data warehouse we have a
data system for mental health services
we have a data system for the Bureau of
drug and alcohol services so so that's a
whole other area so is is this an area
in health care that is the least
developed from an electronic health
record perspective and so we have most
of or much of our records uh stranded
and sort of a paper-based stovepipe way
I I wouldn't characterize it as that I
would say that there are
um different emrs
um electronic medical records that
providers have
um and whether they speak to each other
or not is a whole other question
um so it's always easier as you know if
we have 10 Community Mental Health
Centers for them to all be on the same
EMR that's not necessarily the case
all right well thanks for that I'll let
you get back to a normal scheduled
program that's okay
this is just a guide and we're certainly
here to answer questions
um as as you see fit
uh step up and step down options we
refer to this and it's become a
shorthand it really is to look at that
opportunity if someone needs to go up
the that means they have a higher level
of care it's really about meeting needs
and stepping down for example coming out
of New Hampshire hospital or a
designated receiving facility and having
an intermediary step before
community-based services
the crisis and inpatient Services I
think you're all very familiar with that
especially since we were here to speak
to you about mobile crisis teams and our
New Hampshire rapid response system
um and we have our inpatient with New
Hampshire hospital in Hampstead and our
designated receiving facilities and this
is
um for those acute crises
the next slide is
um the high level view of our
organization and so you will see
something that's new
um so we have had since 2016 The Bureau
for children's Behavioral Health drug
and alcohol services our policy section
which has specialized services in
Medicaid and legislation and Rule uh
Bureau of Mental Health Services but
what's new here is to the far right the
Bureau of homeless services so this is a
recent development it happened probably
about a month ago maybe maybe a little
bit longer and the idea was that
because a lot of our services hinge on
critical housing
supports and needs that it was the best
fit for our division and the bureau used
to sit with the Bureau of economic and
housing stability I mean the division of
Economic and housing stability and now
has landed so to speak at home with us
so just to understand that a little uh
deeper
um
our citizens can be homeless for a lot
of different reasons uh I I think it got
placed in your department because the
most common reason is because they have
mental health or behavioral health
issues yes but it's not exclusive so
like you could end up with somebody
who's got you know say a chronic care
problem and they're on Medicaid and they
also happen to be homeless and and they
would this department would still try to
worry about how to how to take care of
that absolutely and you'll find that in
all of our services
um for example in our Bureau of drug and
alcohol Services we have the impaired
driver program not everyone who's in the
impaired driver program has a substance
use disorder so so in the entire
Department of Health and Human Services
or is this the only entity we would find
that is directly responsible for
managing uh sort of uh
the acquisition and assignment of of
State controlled housing for clients
no
um so for homeless services this is that
and that's why you see somewhat of a
name change to homeless Services we do
not
um acquire property or have providers
acquire property I think um some of um
what you're referring to would be in
other areas of the state including the
New Hampshire Housing Finance Authority
and the Community Development Finance
Authority they have housing projects and
I know a lot of attention was paid when
we received the arpa funding and the
rental assistance that's all outside of
our department and certainly outside of
the division
there are other Housing Services also in
long-term services and supports
in addition to this particular Bureau
so if there are multiple departments
within the DHHS the the first sort of
budgetary or organizational concern
is
the integration of the services to avoid
gaps in overlaps and and and this is a
relatively new area are you convinced
that you've already got adequate
coordination so that we don't have gaps
in overlaps already
yes I think we're going to get there
with this new placement of this
particular Bureau we have Housing
Services in our Drug and Alcohol
Services Bureau in our mental health
Bureau and what we have already found in
the first few weeks is that there is a
lot of opportunity to leverage our
resources together so that we know that
we're meeting an individual's need in
that a particular
program in the federal government that
can be matched with another program in
the federal
depart federal government they can be
brought together and brought to bear and
so that we don't have duplication of
services and that we have more
coordination of Housing Services
now
um there my feeling on this instinct is
that we probably don't have a good
unifying I.T system to help coordinate
all that data and and just the
information part of it is that is that a
good assumption and if so what are we
going to do about that
so it's a pretty good assumption there
are different requirements there is a
management system for HUD for Housing
and Urban Development that's required
for us to use and then we have in our
other programs for example or housing
Bridge subsidy program in mental health
services that is not even what you would
call an I.T system so there's plenty of
opportunity there to bring that all
together we have I'm not that's not an
area that we have a robust plan but it
is something that we're going to be
looking at as we have have this
opportunity here with the with the new
Bureau we also are going to be doing
some planning in the coming months
hopefully we get through the budget
session and then we're going to do some
very very specific planning within the
division to address some of these needs
in some of the gaps and some of the
opportunities
representative Hershey did you have a
question I did thank you so much
um I'm just curious if you have
a client who has behavioral health
issues who is houseless
and you can assist
in taking away that one
stress factor and getting them housed
does that
bring forth care in a more rapid manner
by just getting them housed or is that
just
the tip of the iceberg I guess I I
appreciate the fact that we're seeing
that the interconnection of it
um I'm just curious it's sort of like a
chicken and an egg kind of thing I'm
just wondering what your thoughts are on
that
so I think it really depends on the
individual and individual situation but
there is the national model that is
housing first and that in order to
anyone to begin to address their needs
they need to be housed first and stable
first so they need you know the the
Maslow if you look at the hierarchy of
need that you need to have shelter and
you need to have food and and that kind
of thing and then you can start to
address some of the more complex
problems
um for behavior in the behavioral health
field so
um that's um really the approach so
would you say that's a priority before
we can provide proper care to these
persons
I think that what is a challenge and
you'll see that here is that
um housing it it housing is a priority
so I was let me just leave it at that
so it's not just housing right the
public health people would tell us that
we have the whole social determinants of
care and and that housing is one
component of that so just to bring us up
to speed are you able to like tick off
the other major social determinants of
care
um so there's one
yeah um so for economic reasons so
um funds you know having a job or having
access to Fred to fresh water
um and food and I'm sorry yeah
I didn't finish education is another
um so yeah yeah but housing is a
prominent one especially for the
population that we serve yeah so so one
one of our challenges I think is how do
we get people sufficiently stable on you
know the hierarchy of needs to where
they can
begin to effectively Engage The the care
component of the system without
going so far that
were disempowering them as individual
responsible people responsible for their
own lives you know taxpayers can't step
in and wrap everyone up in a in a bubble
that's there's just not enough money to
go around for that and it may not be
good social policy
but that's that's a that's a different
debate all right thank you do you have
any other questions
five um so this just shows our full-time
equivalence in each of the areas
so the first we have six within um
the at the division level with that
policy unit and then you can see the
subsequence so we have a total of 54
full-time equivalents
Sean uh I'm sorry on page six where you
say You're Building one of your
accomplishments was building out the
children's system of care that's not
meant to imply that it's done no and
that's um we it should I was trying to
use a different word other than
continued but we're continuing to build
it out but that wasn't a significant
accomplishment is to not only Build It
Up out but Build It Up um we started
from scratch essentially
um when we and we'll go through that
slide on the timeline
um but no we're not done
norger
uh sorry I'm still on page five
um
so
authorized Physicians are these
positions filled or what's the status of
them are you able to hire people and
keep them or yeah so we went through a
period of time where we had um a
significant number of vacancies but more
recently we've been able to fill them so
we only have a handful that are open
right now and there are in active
recruitment but we've been doing pretty
well and we've been very pleased with
the quality of the candidates and have
scored some big wins with some
individuals who have come from the
community and doing direct service at
the community level thank you
yep
welcome representative Wallner no it's
all right
go ahead
great so if we go to slide seven
so we can talk about the Bureau of drug
and alcohol services and you can see the
different accounting units that we have
here
um
[Music]
and why don't we just move right along
to
um to slide eight
so uh bdas as it is affectionately known
is a single state
um substance misuse Authority that's a
designation by the federal government
and you can see what the goals are they
mirror very similar language to the
overall Department mission statement
and again at the bottom of the slide
you'll see a familiar theme with the
bubbles and looking at the Continuum in
the substance misuse system which
includes the prevention and education
crisis access
outpatient and residential treatment and
then very much a huge part of the work
that we do in the community does is peer
recovery Support Services as well as
family support
so I was I was thinking last night about
something I might have asked yesterday
and it just didn't occur to me the when
we have people dying from
overdoses those are recorded as
accidental deaths
that's so far it's a true statement uh
so I'm curious because other states are
debating that categorization whether or
not they should be considered accidental
deaths or some form of homicide
has your department been involved in any
conversations about the proper way for
us to be reporting those overdose deaths
accidental I think it was implied
yesterday basically
um take some of the onus off of the
state for Action whereas something in a
more you know closer to what's happening
this is It's a form of homicide in a way
my focus our minds a little bit more do
you have do you have any thoughts on
that
I think that
that's something that I'm
not with with that categorization so if
I recall yesterday director Tilly had
indicated that those categories were
based off of federal standards and
guidelines and that's why we had
categorized them as such but I know that
she I believe she had some level of
detail below that but that's why they
were showing up in that level
um yesterday just based off the
direction we get from the federal
government
um and as you know the chief medical
examiner is the one who records the
cause of death and that becomes the
official record
and I have not heard what you referenced
so
um I'm just trying to okay
um so slide nine
um this again just another depiction of
the
um services that are provided under this
Bureau and we have you know I was
looking at this this morning I won't
tell you what time but under prevention
and education where you see surveillance
so just to take that um head-on that
includes the
um checks the alcohol checks underage
alcohol checks with retailers that
you've seen for years and that is
funding that we provide to
The Liquor Commission to conduct those
checks but not just to do gotchas on the
retailers but also to educate them in
what signs to look for for
um
underage
attempts to make purchases
so what I think I just heard is that
this there's probably Federal money
coming in under surveillance that hits
your budget and then you transfer it to
uh enforcement
um just order of magnitude about how
much money are we talking about we have
fifty thousand dollars budgeted each
year okay that that's not a lot for
going and surveilling
MIP minor in possession we also use
Governor's commission funds for that
which would not appear they would appear
in the governor's commission line but
would not appear in the unit that Nathan
just referenced all right thanks
um so I referenced earlier under Crisis
Intervention obviously we have the
opioid epidemic response treatment
services and the impaired driving
program
that is self-supported by the way that
is paid for by the individuals who
undergo the program
and then support again recovery
Community organizations they're
scattered throughout the state and have
a facilitating organization Family
Support Services and Recovery housing
all right just keep looking to make sure
there are no questions try to pause
um page 10
um this is called out specifically
because there is so much discussion
around it the state opioid response
grant that we receive right now we
receive about 28 million dollars a year
and that's on the federal fiscal year
um and this is specifically to address
um opioid use disorder and they did
expand it
um more recently to allow us to address
individuals with
um methamphetamine issues as well but it
is one of those areas I did hear
director Tilly yesterday talk about
those categories and the funding that
comes through is very specific to that
program this is very specific to a
population that
misuses opioids or meth and so we have
to be very careful in our reporting that
all of the programs that we Fund in
their mult a multitude of them that they
are used specifically for those
individuals
so as long as you have our attention the
the other thing that's creeping into our
opioid situation is the supplemental
drug that starts with an m and I've
never been good with drug names but the
xylazine is at the
yeah the one that's being used to
stretch the Fentanyl and enhance the
effect and it screws up narcan's
Effectiveness that whatever that one is
would you would you educate us because I
think it's a new trend that is worth
understanding
so xylazine is a drug that has been
found by the state lab to be included in
with the Fentanyl and with other
substances and it is a drug that is not
a controlled drug it is used by
veterinarians for
tranquilization and sedation for their
procedures and it now it has shown up
here it's shown up in other states and
it is not
typically found in and of itself to be
used it's usually mixed with something
and therefore
naloxone one of the things that's really
important is that naloxone should always
be the first line of defense when
addressing someone who is believed to
have overdosed
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and so it's something that we're
watching and commissioner Quinn of
safety has been talking a lot about this
and we've been doing some education
around it just knowing that um
individuals
may not have any idea what's what
they're taking
and um so so that's that's that with
xylazine it's pretty scary stuff she so
in here you have a Community Education
component and so this is a huge new
thing that really needs educating right
yes
so um there was some funding that was
provided I believe it's arpa funding
that went to the Department of Safety
and they have a no safe experience
campaign that either has launched or is
about to launch that addresses the very
education that you're talking about
all right
um
so
unless there are any questions about the
opioid response Grant I will move on to
slide 12 which is the Bureau for
children's Behavioral Health
foreign
so as I indicated the bureau the
division was formed in 2016 and this is
the same time the bureau was formed as
well previously all of our Behavioral
Health Services for children sat within
the division for children youth and
families and it was typically only
provided to individuals who were
involved with gcyf in either child
welfare or child protection and so the
commissioner at that time decided that
we really needed to elevate children's
Behavioral Health and not have it be
just available to those those involved
with dcyf so it came out and became its
own Bureau I think at the time there
were two staff members we've gone up a
little since then and we've had some
significant
um
initiatives that have happened over the
last several years
so
you need to orient them are they good on
that I I I I think I'm looking at page
1031 of the but briefing budget or
budget briefing book
um and one thing that seems different
certainly from yesterday is the ratio of
of General to federal funds in this area
uh it's roughly you know seven to three
um what can you just talk to us about
what's going on here from a matching
perspective and what we're taking on by
ourselves as a state sure so in in the
division for Behavioral Health just kind
of speaking at a global level we do
receive a number of block grants
um and and there's a maintenance of of
effort component to those we do in some
of our accounts and I'm speaking broadly
here I don't know if we want to go
through each one we do have some
Medicaid Administration that we can
claim within some of these accounts we
have our soar funds we have a couple of
other more temporary funds you'll see a
few accounts that are actually fading
out because those funds are no longer
available but in general
the difference between public health is
a large chunk you know close to 70
percent of that is funded through uh I
don't know how many grants off the top
of my head but probably close to 200 or
so grants that we have there versus this
area where there are only a select few
block grants and some Medicaid
administrative dollars that that we can
claim so that's a major distinction from
yesterday's presentation to make here
so so that that implies that there's a
maintenance of effort requirement in
this account or or were you just
speaking more generally
um I was speaking more generally
um in this account so are you referring
to 2052
uh it would be under children's
Behavioral Health I see on page 1031 I
don't I don't see a line number for the
revenues but it's 392 000 of federal
which sounds to me like there's some
allocation between various grants to to
come up with that number no so that's
the um the Medicaid administrative uh
rate that we can claim here in this
account
okay and that is independent of the
state support or is there a maintenance
of effort there to to I I believe that
that portion there is a match is that
correct
yes yes that that that is the match so
this is a weird match because it's
normally at least 50 50 and this this
falls short of that
yes I believe it or is that 50 50 or
there's uh Kyra Leonard our finance
director for dbh um it just indicated to
me that there's mixed funding here so
we're not able to claim that 50 50 rate
that you traditionally saw in the
Medicaid accounts uh and elsewhere are
we leaving money on the table with the
match opportunities no all right
and we got nine people here to to what
extent do these folks coordinate for
example with like the Hampstead Hospital
and other components of of our system of
care
thank you very much for that question
that's a really good point so um what I
should have indicated at the beginning
of the presentation is our very close
relationships that we have with both New
Hampshire hospital and Hampstead
Hospital I would say um Rebecca Ross who
is um the director of the
um the Bureau for children's Behavioral
Health is here but those of those nine I
would say almost all of them interact
with Hampstead in in the coordination
um it's a very
um small uh staff but they're very well
cross-trained and
um do a great job
so I'm I'm gonna
don't overread what I'm about to say I'm
going to challenge us strictly from a
mean Financial perspective before we had
Hampstead we had nine people in this
office now we have Hampstead and we
still have nine people in this office
did we miss an opportunity to to relook
our Force structure do we still need
nine or did because we added this huge
resource in Hampstead that we've maybe
obviated some of the need at the at the
department level I wish it were that
that were the case however it's not
um The Bureau and the division for
Behavioral Health are responsible for
the community-based services you if we
go back to the original Bubbles and we
look at where we are in those
the Hampstead Hospital is the on the far
right side in the inpatient acute level
and the Bureau for children's Behavioral
Health and all of the work that's done
in the system of care is before it gets
to that level and so all of the work is
really overseeing
um the the programs that help support
that and we can go a little bit more
into those we have a couple of different
ways that you can look at it but this is
a system that really has been built is
being built as we look at what's needed
to have that full continuum
and Rebecca will
um I would be remiss if I didn't say
nine is not enough to handle the level
of work we do eligibility she has staff
that does eligibility for the fast
forward program and there is a lot of
coordination for residential services
which we're responsible for whether
someone is dcyf involved or not and
overseeing all of those contracts and
all of those placements of children
throughout the state and Beyond
Okay so
because you sound so convincing that
nine is not enough did you submit to the
governor increase request here or what
what what would you really need
so one of the things that um
so I would say no we did not uh for ask
for the a position within the within the
bureau knowing that um there are
opportunities to um and we had one
instance um in this particular biennium
where
um a a position can be transferred in an
existing position that could be
transferred in
um welcome
um
okay those are my questions are there
any other questions on this area
thank you
all right do you want me to go on or
move on to another Bureau
did did we I don't know if we hit the
whole systems of care I got hung up on
children's Behavioral Health yep so this
is uh still staying within Children's if
you look at
um slide 14 we can just look at the
accomplishments this is talking about
um going back to your point is building
out no we haven't built it out we're
continuing to build out
um the system of care and one of the
significant efforts that has been taking
place is to
um establish the residential treatment
system
um and so you can see that in the top
accomplishment we have the
community-based services through the
Care Management entities and this is
where I reference fast forward that
program which is families and systems
together is what that stands for and you
may have heard about Trek from uh
director ripson talking about the
transitional residential enhanced care
coordination which is really doing that
work for care coordination at the
residential and psychiatric treatment
level which is um
aforementioned Hampstead
and then something that's pretty new
that we've wanted to do for a long time
and now have been able to is looking at
the zero to six population and doing
care coordination to support
those kids as well as their caregivers
in more in in the programming that we do
so so at the bottom of page
1031 I'm looking at the funds the
federal funds are a little over a
million State funds are just over 17 5
million so this this is a relatively
expensive area
given that it doesn't appear that we
have a match can can we talk about uh
the match situation and what
opportunities there might be for other
grants to get some support in this area
sure so so what if if it's helpful I can
just walk through each each funding
source line if if that helps sure
um in so if you look at 23 adjusted
authorized uh you'll see the transfers
from other agencies this is a system of
care grant that we actually receive from
the Department of Education it goes
directly to them from the federal
government and that's transferred into
this class line the federal dollars you
see there that's the administ that's the
um the Medicaid administrative rate that
we claim
um and and we claim as much as we
possibly can just to address your
earlier point there there's a history
behind
um the the the general fund dollars um
back in 2019 hb4 had appropriated 13.1
million dollars for the system of care
and then in the current in the current
hb2
additional some of the unspent funds
were carried forward and then that's
reflected within that within that 2023
adjusted authorized and then those funds
are continued forward into that 24 and
years as well so so there was a
legislative
authorization just a few years ago for
the system of care support
okay so
um I want to I want to tie two things
together when when we talk about the
sununu replacement Center one of the
things that there's some hope for is
um that the overall system of care as we
build it out uh that that's going to
reduce the footprint of the number of
people who are are kept in the in the
future facility
um it it when so when we're talking
about that system of care is this is
this really the preponderance of what
we're talking about as a 17.7 million
dollar
effort to improve community-based care
or their other major ones
great good morning Marissa hen associate
commissioner
um I'm glad you're bringing this up and
I think that the just one thing I would
add to katja's comments first is that
as associate commissioner one of the
things I do is convene
um Katya Fox Rebecca Ross Joe ribsum
from dcyf and Kathy Collins the CEO of
Hampstead Hospital every other week
sometimes more often to look for these
opportunities for integration it is core
to everything we're doing and as Joe
described it's really the reason we're
beginning to get the data to see that
the reason we've been able to achieve
such a low census a six-fold reduction
in five years
is not necessarily because those kids
are being shifted to residential
programs but is because the programs
like Fast Forward are offering those
wraparound supports to support families
underlying needs in their homes and so I
think we're beginning to finally get
that data to show that it's because of
the system of care work and the work
that Katy and Rebecca have led that is
yielding improvements not only for
families with behavioral health issues
but also those who are interfacing with
the juvenile justice system so it's so
you've hit the nail on the head in terms
of understanding what the vision is and
how we're effectuating that in a
day-to-day sense
so so the challenge for the legislature
at least my challenge is trying to
understand what you have internalized
because you have been working it day to
day for several years and that is just
saying seeing that level of integration
between the the programs and the efforts
and the success metrics and the
individual budgets because I think the
individual budgets are probably
stovepipe representations of various
aspects of what we're trying to do and
so if one was to try to understand the
connection of the money to the solution
efforts that would that's kind of
difficult for us to see in in this
approach
I share your your concern and your
desire for more data to even get at that
sort of return on investment that we we
need to see and what are the appropriate
budgets part of the challenge here is
this is relatively new right so the
system of care design was took many
years and now we're seeing the fruits of
that and so I think it is incumbent on
us to be able to understand what the
budgetary realities and changes are
relative to its impact so would you
believe that when I go to national
conferences and I ask reps from other
states what they're doing with system of
care that term means nothing to anyone
is that a uniquely New Hampshire term
for a concept or I don't think it's
uniquely New Hampshire in my experience
nationally I think we're among the
leading States when it comes to
achieving the system of care Vision
um director ribson was actually invited
to a National Conference just last week
to present on some of the the
groundbreaking work that's been done
again with many of those
aspects of impact being felt not only at
a at an individual family level not only
in terms of the youth being served at
Hampstead who are in acute situations
but also on the preventive level the the
vast reduction in kids entering our
Juvenile Justice System
do you want to answer me
I I I was just going to say um so so
this is of course the first time that
I've had the pleasure of of going
through this process in my role
um I do have on the books right now next
fall to start to look at the accounting
structure because you know when we have
an activity over here an account over
here but it's within the division I I
recognize the fact that it can be
difficult a to manage internally but B
from an external transparency
perspective to understand how do these
things align so I'm going to be looking
at that
um for the for the subsequent budget to
see what we can do internally
um both from a management perspective
while still being able to be transparent
with the accounting structure and the
way that that is being presented that
that that is a priority for me in this
coming year just so you understand that
that will be addressed going forward so
I'm going to go to representative erf in
just a second and and that I I I just
want to point out what I think you're
you know and that you're flying in your
answer
is that during these budget efforts uh
the legislature who's been rep or voted
in by to represent the public uh this is
the our opportunity to make sure that
the public has transparency under
understands that we're investing the
money wisely and to the extent that a
lot of this activity is just really hard
for us to perceive and to integrate in
our own minds our ability to explain it
and defend it then to the public who's
paying for it is just diminished and I I
think you get all of that so so I'm glad
you're going to relook that and good
luck because I don't know an easy way to
correlate something that's this systemic
you know but representative
thank you Mr chair so this is a
substantial increase in budgeting for
this this next biennium and that's not
even accounting for the fact that it's
not clear you'll even spend the FY 23
just unauthorized this year
can you describe what this extra fund
what these extra funds are why there's
so much more in this account
sure so so I I can just begin
um so a significant portion of these um
will fall within the contracts line for
the fast forward program and care
coordination and count down if you want
to speak to more specifics
so um a couple things on this a little
bit broader
um again as I had said this was a system
that didn't exist so now some of the
funding that you're seeing was showing
up in a whole bunch of different areas
um for to meet kids needs now we have
the opportunity to contract so before we
didn't contract with our Residential
Treatment providers now we contract with
them and um so some so that shows up
here fast forward was a very small
program it's rapidly expanding
and you'll see that in the in the
numbers that we get into with our our
slide presentation so
um so yeah it's it's something that we
are we need to pay for because it's a
way to intervene and to get kids the the
care they need in the right place
okay I sort of answer the question I
guess like because you know is what why
is it going up so dramatically
um are you expecting to expend the all
that adjusted authorized funding and can
you tell us maybe not right now but can
you let us know what other what are
these other areas where things came from
and now they're a part of this uh piece
as well
sure
um and yes I expect that we will expend
all of those funds um we carried them
forward because we had the lag time
um in getting the system up and running
and getting those contracts in place so
I expect that we will expend those funds
we actually had a prioritized need and I
think that Nathan is going to be
bringing forth all of our prioritized
needs in a package to you when you have
the opportunity to talk about those to
actually have additional funding for
those Residential Treatment providers
because they
um the the rate that was initially put
into those contracts is proving not to
be sufficient to support the provider's
needs
when it comes to Staffing again
Workforce shortage the ability to staff
up as well as all the increased costs
due to inflation
Okay so
this number of General funds in 24 17
million 779 110
implies tremendous specificity
how how did we come up with a number of
this specific why isn't it just a
hundred dollars instead of a hundred and
ten for example
I I don't know if there's necessarily
um an easy answer I can get the details
behind them if you'd like the ground
level details to show I don't need the
details I'm just trying to hear how
detailed what your methodology and
process is to come up with a number this
precise and something that seems
pretty diffuse and difficult to put a
finger on
ES
okay
um so so vast majority of it is is based
on the actual contract the price
limitations that that we have
um and and then there's there's a couple
of under other underlying subtleties
behind those figures but but it is based
on on actual data it's not just we chose
a odd number to to determine what the
amount should be
all right thank you of course I know I I
realize it's a hard question but and
that's something you're going to be
diving into in August September anyways
to try to figure out how to rationalize
all of these organized organized
okay any questions here I I think we can
go on
okay and I um first slide uh 15 just
again the key challenges that um we have
seen in the reports I think you have
seen in the headlines about the increase
in the number of Youth experiencing
Behavioral Health needs
people ask me why
we all grew up we did not have the level
of behavioral health problems at least
not so publicly and so openly
and I'm just and so people ask me why
what has happened
um
smartphones for 12 year olds is it you
know is it uh the breakdown of two
parent families is it you know what what
why are we having these problems what
what can we do systemically to try to
make a healthier Society
I think it is so complex so it's what
you said in much much more
um and one um thing that comes to mind
is those bubbles again when we look at
prevention and we look at building
resiliency in our children so that um
although we're not going to be able to
take away phones and social media we
certainly can build the resiliency in
our children so that those don't have a
significant impact and I don't remember
in my time period in generation that we
had anything as significant
as a pandemic happen
but this is this has been trying yes the
pandemic was problematic and uh
exacerbated issues but I think I think
we've been on a trend for quite a long
time and I to what extent are we
investing in trying to really make sure
we understand the drivers of the trend
to try to come up with uh solutions to
problems rather than spending money on
symptoms because it feels like a lot of
this is potentially money being spent to
address symptoms of a much bigger
problem rather than addressing the
underlying problems themselves that's
that's my feeling
yeah so um we're not undergoing research
studies within the division but there is
there are ongoing studies and there's
Research into that again we're trying
from what we do have the ability to
impact which is looking at prevention
and looking at those evidence-based
practices that help help in for the
future today and the future
so if we had research for example that
said it's probably not a good idea to
have kids under the age of 16 with
smartphones
just as an example
should we be issuing Public Health
warnings or advisories or putting it
into our community uh education efforts
that that one of the things that may be
contributing to some of this are
the Technologies in the hands of people
unable to cope with
the access to the world it's creating
I think that when we have evidence and
the research behind it that it's our job
to educate the public it's not to
necessarily vilify one particular
thing such as cell phones or alcohol or
tobacco but really to look at all of our
public policy and our laws surrounding
those yeah so just so you know
technology has always been a problem
right I mean when cameras came out there
was all this societal concerns about
privacy because cameras were available
and then the transistor radio broke kids
away so they weren't listening to
Lawrence Welk they were listening to
Elvis Presley so technology is always
kind of on at the at the cusp of a lot
of the social change I'm just again I I
I just I just want us to have a healthy
society and I it feels it to be truly
truly cynical what you might hear
somebody say in a quiet moment is that
um the the the the the the first
motivation of any organization is to
grow and so we're creating a behavioral
health industry whose objectives is is
like any other organization is to grow
are we are we compounding a problem
or addressing a problem I that that
that's the big thing I wrestle with and
there's it's not an answer for today uh
but but that's I just wanted to put it
out there is that that as we talk to the
public there are there are cynics
amongst us that think that we've CR
we've we've created an industry that's
now self-perpetuating so
um
representative walner thank you
I was wondering what
I would say
Elder and who grew
up their Mental Health
so I
um I don't have a response to that
um and because I think there's research
that shows about children who grow up
and so we talk about the Aces and so we
talk about adverse childhood experiences
and I think it's now become so common in
our vernacular that we just say Aces and
we don't talk about what aces are so
Aces include sexual abuse physical abuse
verbal abuse
and a whole a whole array of services
having
domestic violence in a home having
someone with a substance misuse disorder
in your home so there's a whole array of
service of research that looks and tries
to quantify
those experiences to determine what
impact they have on individuals as an
adult but then you have to also factor
in those protective factors and that's
why I keep talking about the prevention
and the protective factors because those
are so important for children as they
grow
and the and really trying to mitigate
those adverse experiences with positive
other perfect protective factors in
prevention
thank you chair two questions first is I
think I heard the chairman ask relative
to federal funds what additional grants
are out there can you provide I mean
this is this is a 90-10 actually it's
more like 95 to five percent right
funded through state
is there a way for you to let us know
and if we invested in a grant writer or
something else would there be access to
Greater federal funds question one
so I I know Nathan wants to respond one
of the reasons why this is so heavily
reliant on General funds is because
they're not Medicaid reimbursable
services so when we have the opportunity
to have a service and Bill Medicaid then
we can say it's 50 50. but a lot of
these services are not eligible for that
we may have some opportunities to open
up some what is known as opening up
codes that we could turn on which costs
money but does also allows us to draw
down that other 50 percent
and and I I from uh from a capacity
perspective generally speaking it's not
that we need more grant writers
um I I think we have many people within
the department that are capable of that
um when we do identify grants we always
look at what are the associated
requirements because sometimes there's
really heavy reporting and that could be
programmatic aspects that could be uh
Financial aspects that that do you know
do have a burden and so
um a grant itself if it's a really small
dollar amount it could cost us more to
actually administer it because we have
audit requirements that we're going to
deal with for the next couple years
Associated we have quarterly reporting
requirements we have you know whether
they're Financial programmatic we have
the accounting information that we have
to deal with the invoices resulting from
any contracts that have to be reviewed
on a monthly basis so two hundred
thousand dollars towards a specific
purpose for a Federal grant may look
good on paper but we always have to ask
the question what does that take away
because there there are dozens of other
individuals involved in the
administration of every grant that comes
through understand
um and then secondly
what would it take if we wanted you guys
to do additional research relative to
what are the underlying causes
um right would this be another person
how do we prioritize trying to make sure
that we're looking at the system inputs
um as opposed to just re being in a
reactionary mode there's a lot more
return on investment for dollars and and
time and and precious resources when
you're addressing the underlying factors
that are that are driving this and is
that another person what is that to make
that happen
so that's a great question
um I don't think it's a per a state
staff person because we don't
necessarily have those skills nor would
we want to acquire I'm probably pretty
expensive Endeavor we do have a number
of Consultants that we have worked with
and who are currently contracted with us
to evaluate our programs to see if
they're effective in getting the
outcomes that we desire so we have that
happening
um
we oh I struggle and personally struggle
when we put money into research and
evaluations when we have such a great
need for the services on the ground and
what role should my division have and
what um role should the department have
in conducting that research versus
providing services to our to our
citizens
I understand that
um that the issue right of trying to
deal with real world needs
versus right trying to find out what's
causing these but if you want to solve
the problem long term right when you're
constantly fighting the fire a real
world needs you never get ahead of it
the problem just continues to grow so
even a small amount invested early on
has a huge return long term because who
knows maybe this is a breakdown of the
family that's going to be a tough
problem to solve with in the department
for instance right single-family homes
versus traditional two two parent homes
that that is not an easy knob that you
guys might be able to adjust but if it
comes down to
screen time broadly speaking as a father
of teenage children
um I right that may be something where
Health advisory notices and helping
parents understand that hey it's it's
good for for young boys to go outside
and play with right play in the front
yard and run around because burning off
that excess energy is helpful as opposed
to that excess energy being diverted
toward misbehavior
so um believe me I I totally support the
research I think it's happening and I
think it's happening at the national
level with a variety of different think
tanks so what we can do is bring back
some of that research that's ongoing and
that has been published
following up on something else she said
I wanted to see if I understood it
correctly you talked about opening up
codes to me that may mean that their
services that would be eligible for 50
match under Medicaid that we don't
currently offer in the state of New
Hampshire
um can you first is that correct and
second can you uh do you have any
examples of of any of those are there
any of those that you think should be
seriously considered
so your assumption was correct and I
would need to come back to you with
those examples
okay thank you please do
so because I love this slide on slide
three and it's kind of related to to the
conversation we just had
um your your bubbles don't include the
need to do uh or the authority related
to original Research into the causation
the societal causation right so
um but what would be nice is to know
that somewhere in the department there's
a group or an individual trying to
monitor
um what's going on in Academia
uh and and looking for you know the the
Strategic problems and and and to have
dialogues about maybe strategic
Solutions
and and I get where you're coming from
Miss Fox here
you're busy right and and so so this is
probably some deep thinker somewhere
that's just looking at the big picture
um and we have contracts with the
University of New Hampshire already I
don't know what all of those contracts
provide I assume some of it is uh we're
already paying for uh coordination and
assistance from the research Community I
I I I just
suggesting that we find a way to try to
get up out of the day-to-day and look
in the big picture but
there's not anything for you to respond
to there that's just me yakin
um and our associate commissioner does
want to respond but I will say we can
we have contracts with the institute on
disability at UNH we have contracts with
Dartmouth College
um and um I think Dartmouth Medical
Center and we have a contract with
Brandeis so we do have Partnerships with
our academic institutions for a variety
of reasons um and importantly the the
evaluation component so I will um I will
let associate commissioner hen respond
um I want to say that I appreciate this
dialogue because I think the the
emphasis on getting upstream and The
Importance of Being evidence-based is um
is crucial to this conversation
I have a doctorate in public health uh
the reason as someone who's academically
rooted that I wanted to come to this
position just under two years ago was
because of the in large part the
commitment of of Katya of our
commissioner of the whole department in
in connecting to that rigorous
data-oriented standards so well while
Katya is modest and I think
appropriately so in um in making sure
that you know she's connected to the
research we are engaged not only
um connected to an array of national
bodies
um and contributing to learning
collaboratives and various conferences
and so forth but actually New Hampshire
is being called on in many different um
respects to provide our expertise to
National decision makers and other state
leaders on how they can learn from the
success that we've yielded the system of
care probably being one of the most
important areas where we've been able to
stand that up so quickly with such fast
effects that other states want to know
how we're doing that
um and so I think the whole at one other
thing I just want to emphasize from
earlier in the conversation the entire
premise of the system of care is to
engage preventively to reduce Reliance
on institutional settings and to connect
kids with the services they need in
their communities in a trauma-informed
family-centered way so I just want to I
want to say that we agree violently
vehemently with what you're saying
that's really the whole premise here
um and as Joe also alluded to because
because dcyf is as connected to the
system as anyone five years ago if Joe
ribsum's team wanted to connect a family
with Services there had to be an actual
allegation or an open case around abuse
or neglect talk about misaligned
incentives I mean we've come so far in
terms of being able not only through the
Bureau of children's Behavioral Health
and through the whole Continuum to be
able to support families early but also
doing so through the preventive services
that he talked about so I just want to
say we agree totally I think it's
embedded in everything we're doing and
while I appreciate Katya not wanting to
overstay our engagement in research and
data everything from you know the yrbs
youth behavioral risk surveys that
Trisha Tilly helps connect us with we
are we are reviewing that data regularly
we are committed to um to an
evidence-based approach
thanks
not not to not to make light of what you
just said but just to make light of the
intensity of the problem
I'm really looking forward to in a month
from now you're coming back with the
three things we need to do at a societal
level to fix the problem so if you could
just fix the problem we wouldn't need to
spend as much money that way that's all
um that sounds like a much deeper
research project than most phds ever
undertake yeah yeah are all right so I'm
gonna I'm gonna let you get going again
and I'm going to apologize for making
this a very unusual budget briefing but
I can't I can't look at these programs
and these numbers without trying to
figure out where are we going what what
are we trying to do as a state you know
and how do we explain this to the public
so so thank you representative walner
thank you before we uh go past page 15.
could you just talk a little bit about
the workforce
the shortages in our that our
contractors are having and I mean we've
heard a lot about the state itself the
state employees and the difficulty we're
having but what about the services we're
buying from providers in the community
what kinds of problems and can you talk
about
what that what what
what's causing
um what causes that to happen in
what are we doing to help them
I'm going to speak more generally about
Workforce across the entire
um Division and all the services that we
provide and I think you're going to hear
from the community Behavioral Health
Association after we present this
morning but I think that everyone goes
quickly to wages and wages certainly are
a significant issue they were an issue
prior to the pandemic they've been an
issue post pandemic and they um they are
contributing factor
there is a
this idea that we're in a mental health
crisis I think makes it very
unattractive to want to go into the
field
um so I think there's that as a factor I
think that we do not have
um the numbers that we need of
individuals who are going into the field
and that can be for a variety of reasons
so there are so many different
strategies that the Endowment for health
has convened a really a Workforce effort
and initiative to look at across the
Health Care system and Fields the why
we're experiencing this but we do know
that wages and a supportive work
environment are a significant
tools that can be used but we really
need to grow the workforce I think that
we see increased demand but we don't
have the numbers that are coming in we
have also in speaking to Maggie
Pritchett who's going to speak after me
she was saying we just people are
retiring they're just retiring they've
reached that age the people who entered
this field have been there they've been
there a long time and and there are some
retirements that are happening
so
how do we encourage
I guess public education to
um
encourage people to go into these fields
and what are the universities or the
colleges doing
to help us get a Workforce
so I think there have been particular
universities and college systems in the
state that have started programs and are
you are actively recruiting certainly
having settings in which they can train
are important one area of shortage has
been at the bachelor's level and most of
our a lot of our requirements are around
Master's level and so we we end up
seeing that the bachelor level
um
clinicians or Frontline staff there's
High turnover because of that okay I get
my training ground and then I can move
on to another position that's either a
career advancement
um or is
um frankly less stressful
so there you know there's some if
anybody had this um figured out then we
wouldn't have this problem and that's
why there have been so many initiatives
in so many ways um that people are
trying to address it not just in New
Hampshire but across the country
thank you uh based on that in terms of
the schools that are graduating students
that are in subjects relevant to your
department
just ballpark do you feel as though
you're getting most from New Hampshire
schools or outside of New Hampshire or a
combination a ballpark percentage I'm
not looking for execs I wish I knew on
that number but I do think I'm again
following on the community Behavioral
Health Association they do a Workforce
report on a monthly basis and they talk
about the recruitment
um and so Maggie might be able to Ms
Pritchard might be able to answer that
question more directly
um I I don't know I think um I did see
um with the Endowment for health and
that initiative around Workforce that um
it's it's really
um not the attracting people from out of
state that's happening that is filling
those open positions that it really is
people from from New Hampshire
and that our efforts to go recruit and
talk about the the you know dream that
we're going to be making it more
attractive
um to come over from Vermont uh per se
um that that's that's putting a lot of
effort into very little gain and the
gain should be here uh within the state
go ahead
thank you very quick follow-up very
related does the University system of
New Hampshire and the community college
system support the programs that you
need for the workforce that you require
I I can't answer that blanket they do
support programs that we do need
for example the School of Social Work at
UNH
um but I would have to probably get back
to you I'm more specific if there's a
gap in a particular program thanks
point my sense on that from friends on
the education committee is we have major
components all throughout the system
like in high school and and into the
community college system and they're
trying to bridge all that stuff I I
suspect like any time you have workflow
you're trying to make sure that you can
coordinate between the the bubbles
um and just overall we I think even in
there we have a capacity issue so even
if we have a component of the solution
there's probably a capacity issue there
as well
so it's my guess
okay Miss Fox you you said something
very gentle in there and and I want to
understand if you had a bigger point you
were trying to make you mentioned the
dream of expanding our Workforce in New
Hampshire I it made me wonder if you
were
referring to the idea that we could make
a massive change in licensures and that
that would be a magnet to draw people
from out of state right if you weren't
meaning to mention that then then that's
okay I just but if that's what you were
referring to I I'd like to hear your
thoughts so no um I wasn't but I do
dream
um but I do dream of a robust Workforce
um often
um no it was just that we put so much
emphasis on thinking that we're going to
attract individuals from other states to
move here to take on this work
um the data doesn't support that in the
work that the endowment has done in that
matter it really talks more specifically
that our best recruitment tool is to
um to use all the resources we have in
New Hampshire
to have New Hampshire
residents take on this work
um however you brought up the licensure
obviously there are a lot of barriers
that have been identified for Workforce
and that we have a narrow view of
Workforce and that what our requirements
were 20 years ago of who could do what
need to change and we've have some
efforts going on in looking at doing
career ladders but also looking at our
peer Workforce
which are
underutilized and could be expanded so
that they have the opportunity to
conduct some of the work that needs to
be done at the community level
so I keep forgetting the term are you in
the second area are you referring to
standards of care or practice standards
of practice or I forget the term what we
call we have something that refers to uh
each job having an evaluation of which
kinds of care they can provide within
that job yeah
categories
is permitted to do what who can develop
a treatment plan who can sign off on a
treatment plan and
Etc so so that's a potential area that
we might also want to supplement some of
our state work on is trying to
reevaluate I God I wish I remember the
term practice scope of practice that's
the term I'm looking for so a kind of a
reevaluation of scope or practice who
who in the department might take a lead
on on sort of a scope of practice review
so I think there are some efforts under
that are um going on through the office
of licensure and um
okay
um office of professional licensure and
certification so that's under a
different department within the state
um and governor sununu also in his
budget address talked about some changes
that he wanted to see so there's a lot
of work happening in this space
um and I'm not sure within who in our
department is on point for that
thank you
representative Waller
what I was wondering was
um what is the department doing about
contracts and increasing
the reimbursement to the contractors so
that they can I mean part of part of the
problem is Wages not all of the problem
is Wages but part of it is and
if we can't if those Community providers
do not have the resources to pay their
the people who work there
um we're gonna have this is going to
continue this will continue so what is
in this budget for increases to the
people we contract with
so specifically so I know um there are a
lot of discussions and director Lipman
was here on Monday to talk about
Medicaid rates and that's how providers
get paid in many instances and those
rates have to cover wages so that's
that's one aspect you don't see it in my
budget you see it in the Medicaid budget
in this particular budget there are many
areas that support wages one that is a
prioritized need that was not funded in
the governor's phase of the budget was
for those Residential Treatment
providers for children's Behavioral
Health and so we had to ask over the
biennium for 25 million dollars to be
able to increase those
contracts with those that particular
those particular providers
was that a prioritized need that was not
included in this budget correct thank
you
all right
I think we've thrown you off your track
that's okay that's all right can you
find where we were I know where we were
but I'm going to skip us a little bit
further beyond that because again we
have the visual depictions of the
children's Behavioral Health System Of
Care on
on both P well we can go we can skip I
think 16 17 and 18 unless anyone
um wants to focus on those areas and we
can go straight to 19.
these are um just to show these next few
charts are to show the growth of the
programs we've talked about fast forward
this is the wraparound services at the
community level and as you can see that
enrollment growth
and on page 20 which is the Trek program
which is for
residential transitions
that also has continued to grow
and when I say I want to talk about this
growth we had projected growth and then
we have growth and this is reflecting
growth beyond what was projected
which is great because people are
getting the services that they need
page 21. this is the uh what I talked
about the zero to six program and it
just launched and so you can already see
that that's ramping up as well
and that concludes the Bureau for
children's Behavioral Health and we can
move on to the Bureau of Mental Health
Services which addresses the adult
population if that works
okay great
um so some of this is going to be
familiar to you as we appeared before
you about a month ago
so this is again Mental Health Services
across the Spectrum looking at the adult
population
and individuals who have a severe mental
illness or a co-occurring substance use
disorder
um on page 23
this is really looking at the
accomplishments again the crisis
response system the Step Up step down
programs which includes those Beds which
are the transitional beds between higher
levels of care and local levels of care
and community
there has been we talked a lot about
housing and we say you know there's just
not enough housing we have been able to
even despite the challenges with housing
we've been able to increase the beds for
Supportive Housing for individuals with
severe mental illness and so you can see
that
um we have the critical time
Intervention Program which is something
that was talked a lot about in the last
biennium and that sorry that implemented
is spelled incorrectly that I just see
right now sorry about that
um but CTI is really looking at helping
with the transition from
a designated receiving facility
including New Hampshire hospital into
the community to address
non-medical needs
thank you
on your bullet point regarding
Fair I'll pretend it's ice cream
um
your bullet point regarding supported
housing from 760 beds or 63 to 1007. can
you ex where are those beds right
there's a shortage of mental health beds
right at the broader level help me
understand how you're solving it here so
we can apply those elsewhere sure
um so what we were able to do is work
with our community mental health centers
and we had um contracted with them for
them to each stand up six additional
beds in their regions for a total of 60
beds I think 48 or so over 40 have come
online that are reflected here and
they've had a variety of different ways
in which to stand up those beds we
didn't dictate it had to be XYZ we said
here is the requirement six beds you
know what is your plan so some of those
beds have been Pier lead beds so that's
pure respite beds some of those beds
have been
um the traditional community the
residents Beds which provides
the on-site staff and supervision and
services
and then there's been independent
housing as well so it's a variety we
have broken that down in the past and we
can do that in and indicate what region
has done has done what with that with
that effort
um and so then moving on to again you've
seen these slides the New Hampshire
rapid response model the key component
being that it's really simple is that
you have a place to call you have
someone to respond based on that call
and that you have somewhere to go we've
done a really good job in standing up
rapid response on the call center the
mobile crisis teams and now where our
area focus is somewhere to go which is
Crisis stabilization and so that's not
just um that's the housing is is longer
term somewhere to go is Crisis
stabilization is looking at more that
okay let's get you into a place where
you can have that assessment you can
have that breather and we can work with
you on your next steps
so since that Court ruling came out I've
monitored some social media discussions
about this and
some folks are saying oh the mobile
response teams are going to be a big
part of solving this patient warehousing
problem and this and this makes my head
hurt because I don't I don't see how
that's a part
of
improving the bed capacity
can you
sure I'd be happy to address that so all
of the community-based services that are
um in this division are based on trying
to address people's needs at the lowest
level of care necessary having an
intervention well before anyone needs to
hit an Ed and it reaches an acute phase
mobile crisis and the rapid response
system was stood up because we knew that
people were showing up in EDS who didn't
need that level of care they didn't need
to go just like you can go to urgent
care or you can go make an appointment
with your PCP rapid response is an
opportunity to take care of someone's
needs right in the community right there
it may even be taking care of their
needs on the phone and having that
personal connection so
um I do think it does divert people from
the emergency departments all right that
makes sense thank you for the education
so um on the next slide just getting a
little bit more into critical time
intervention and the timeline
just for
um your
um what's not appearing here and in
slide 26 is the numbers we've had 205
people who are currently enrolled in
that program which is a nine month
program and we've had 25 who've actually
completed the program and this is a
program that's carried out and is inter
woven with our community mental health
centers
are there any questions here I I just
hoping somebody would ask so I wouldn't
have to ask
okay I I just three sentences on what
what what is what's the per the point of
the CTI program and
so as we talked about in the show I
don't know if this counts towards my
three
um in the children's
um Behavioral Health really looking at
that care coordination
um in between steps and the transitions
this is care coordination that's done
between the facility level and the
community
so it is helping someone and having
someone to talk to maneuver through
renting up an apartment or making sure
that they're applying for eligible
Services ensuring that they have job
searches and how they can go about doing
that so so this is getting them out of
the institutionalized care back into the
community yep so on the on slide 26
there's a a bubble on the bottom right
that's just three month HS and I'm just
curious
is that a typo or am I just needing to
expand my vocabulary
yes oh there we go three months some
formatting issues here sorry no that's
all right I I just
I was just wondering if it was a new
acronym you know so all right keep going
all right
um so looking at the key challenges
within this particular bureaus work
um just looking at the increased demand
which we've talked about the workforce
shortages we've talked about and The
Limited available housing and what I
want to point out with that all despite
our efforts and our success in standing
up beds there still aren't enough
housing units available we have a
housing Bridge subsidy program which is
just that it's a it's a bridge for
someone who has is eligible for the
housing Choice vouchers which was
formerly known as Section 8 and
um they so it's a bridge until they
actually are able to get that voucher
from the FED federal government
and we pay a portion thereof of that
rent we have a
um people who've been approved who have
yet to be able to lease up because they
haven't been able to find an affordable
or an available apartment and so we have
about over a hundred people who have
been approved are eligible for that
program and have yet to be able to
secure housing
on page 27 I'm sorry if I missed it what
is the um
the blue line versus the Orange Line
there on the clients
it's the difference between adults and
children
adults yes yeah sorry that's okay
I don't I don't want to let you get out
of this section and until you you tell
us what you think we know and what we
think we don't know yet about the court
order and what the potential
implications are for recommended
solutions to address the court order and
what kind of money might we expect to be
demanded uh here in a few months or
weeks
sure I I spoke with the the chief legal
counsel for Health and Human Services
before I came here and uh just to make
sure I didn't get in trouble
um and uh and and she told me at this
point in time we really can't speak
um to to the specifics of the plan as
that's currently being developed
um I know that's not helpful for this
committee
um
I I cannot tell you a dollar amount
because I do not know what the plan is
yet
um however I I do think that um we can
when Ellen Lapointe with New Hampshire
hospital comes here next week I believe
for scheduled for Wednesday Wednesday
currently
um that we can have a have some
discussion about what are the challenges
with with the um the workforce that they
have there and some of the bed capacity
um one one thing that I think may just
may feed into that conversation just to
make everybody aware of now
is this past legislative session New
Hampshire hospital actually was provided
the Authority for Recruitment and
Retention incentive payments
um for staff that work there however we
don't currently have any funds budgeted
for that purpose
um we we did have a couple of
prioritized needs included in our budget
for that purpose
um that and all that Ellen speak to this
when she comes before you but that would
certainly provide them with a little bit
more flexibility
um when it does come to trying to
compete with with the nursing uh labor
market that's out there
search trivia question why why when they
got that Authority wasn't there a joint
legislative fiscal committee request to
transfer money is because there was no
more money to to be transferred or was
it an over overlooked or what no
um so so we DHHS was
um we were required to return 22.6
million dollars in general funds from
our Personnel lines and so
um I think I've recalled or recounted
this story before so last spring I
basically sent out a directive to each
area within the department and off the
top of my head I believe New Hampshire
hospital had a three million dollar
general fund reduction that they needed
to hit from their personnel line
um and so because of that we don't
really have a lot of money to um to
provide for those incentives right now
so how about a timeline you can't you
can't you don't know what the plan is
obviously but what what's so when might
the legislature expect
um a solution package and a budgetary
requirement
I I don't until we have a plan
um as as directed by the courts
um I I know the doj is involved with
that
um as well as the hospitals and I
believe they have to come to some kind
of mutually agree upon proposal and
provide that back to the courts before
we would really have a good sense of
what that would cost so until I see that
plan I can't really come up with it
unfortunately I can't come up with a
good dollar figure for you no I know you
can't do dollars I'm just trying to
figure out what the timeline is so are
we talking about a few months are we
talking about a year I guess 29 days
from today
wow okay
are there questions here
all right so I'm going to go to page 29
for the Bureau of homeless services
and
um
and try to walk you through this and
answer your questions we do have the
director of economic stability division
here Karen Hebert because she's doing a
a nice warm handoff of this Bureau to
our division if there's specific
questions that I can't answer so the
first slide on this oh go ahead you want
to orient yes yes and and if you turn to
page 897
um that that's where the the path Grant
the 7926 and on the subsequent page 898
the 7927 is the Housing Shelter program
accounting unit associated with us
and that's another uh thing on Nathan's
to-do list
um and the finance team is that we'll
get the accounting units um all in one
place
um in the next biennium
okay so um these are the three uh
Services the programs that are mostly
the under the administration of the
bureau
um so we've talked about HUD
um this gets really complicated I've
heard it about five times and I'm still
just getting it
um but what there are are there
continuums of care within the state of
New Hampshire and so when you see
balance of state that means everything
except the Manchester area and the
Nashua area those are designated
specifically by the federal government
and we're responsible for the rest of
the state
and again it takes a little while to get
used to when you see balance of State
what does that mean that means that
though we cover those areas and we work
closely with the other uh to uh
continuums of care but are not
responsible for that
so under the projects that are funded
are Supportive Housing rapid re-housing
and a coordinated entry system
we have a grant that provides
those services to homeless and at-risk
households
and in all of these if you look at the
dollar amounts they're pretty small
programs and they're they're small
amounts that we receive which we can
talk about in a little bit
Emergency Shelters this is the most
visible I think from a public knowledge
standpoint of what we support
um and and I think you're familiar with
the shelters and the big ones and that
and they're not so big ones that we have
throughout the state
and some of the challenges that were
faced during the pandemic from a social
distancing standpoint and now from a
capacity standpoint which we we've seen
most visible in Manchester but it's not
unique to Manchester
um then the um the samsa so this is
something that I'm pretty familiar with
as the federal Authority Under This they
help support the uh projects for
assistance in transitioning from
homeless that's the path Outreach and
that is actually funded
um to the Community Mental Health
Centers so again you can see where some
of that natural fit comes in which it's
the same providers providing
um the the services under this program
the um one thing that again you may be
familiar with the discussion we had just
had this in January the point in time
counts this is what we submit to the
federal government and it impacts our
funding formula and this talks about
um where we are on that given day in
that particular year and so you'll see
um we we do a really
um wide
um
Outreach and cast a wide net to make
sure that we get the best count that we
can and so we have those that are in
shelters that are counted that's an
obvious one we have those who are
unsheltered and that's where some of
that Outreach those programs are out
counting and we put those together for
our total and you can see it goes up and
down up and down and unfortunately more
recently it's gone up
so I have some questions here whenever
you we whenever there's a shortage of
resources there has to be some
allocation or prioritization process to
to do the best you can with what you've
got and so we have many categorical many
categories of people who are finding
themselves homeless that we're trying to
provide support for
some of them that come to mind
are veterans I think there's 125
homeless in that category we have
refugees we have
um you know the people with the
substance abuse issues we just have all
these different categories of potential
clients
and um I'm just I'm I'm I'm curious
what we do to to try to make sure that
there's an equitable and and fair way to
to make sure that we're prioritizing who
gets what how to
I mean we
my my fear and you can Ally this or is
is is that we prefer some categories
over others
so I think um in many instances it's our
funding source that has us prioritize
particular categories so you brought up
veterans I believe that that is one
that's
um highlighted as a priority
um I would probably need to defer to
Karen or to our Bureau director who's on
vacation
to get more specifics about how we
prioritize at the at the shelter level
or at the housing level again our
funding sources like I like I indicated
State opioid response is for individuals
who have an opioid use disorder the you
need a category potentially of severe
mental illness to be eligible for
particular housing for for that
population so it's complicated it's not
just necessarily an algorithm that you
put in and you get the so this is yet
another area where we're getting stove
pipe funding things for particular
things from the federal government and
that we have to manage within those
stovepipe boundaries and sometimes it
causes us to not be happy with the
outcome or the result
I would say yes yeah okay and then I'll
just go ahead and ask my ugly question
well well Karen comes up and and that is
um are we are we are are we being forced
or are we choosing to
um support
folks who are in the country illegally
prior to satisfying
all the needs of New Hampshire citizens
there that's an easy one to come up to
good morning for the record Karen Hebert
director of the division of economic
stability thank you for these questions
um
director Fox was correct and that a lot
of our prioritization really is
federally driven by what funding the
Housing and Urban Development agency is
giving opportunities to states to apply
for
um
and you're right they do end up stove
piping a lot of those categories of
individuals whether they're chronically
homeless which they have a specific
definition for whether you have a
disability uh whether you are
um somebody who has AIDS or HIV uh and
other people who have other types of
disabilities that they need or mental
health issues that those particular
funding streams Provide support for so
it's difficult to prioritize them in
that particular Realm
um
but this is really what the the balance
of State this Continuum of Care is
really responsible for where we're
trying to work with a number of
providers in the community a number of
stakeholders where we all come together
and try to determine really what are the
resources that we have available to make
sure that we are addressing each one of
those categories as best as we can
together
and I
I've already forgotten your second
question
it's really smart to forget that one
that's that that's the ugly one about uh
folks who are in the state who are in
our nation illegally are we are we being
required to meet their needs for housing
before or the needs of New Hampshire
citizens are met not necessarily I think
that a lot of these things happen
simultaneously and depends on a number
of factors such as the volume of
individuals who need various types of
services so we have funding that we do
receive from the federal government
specifically for refugees
and that is just we all know refugees
are here legally I'm I'm making the the
explicit distinction about the uninvited
guests who come across the border uh
illegally
because we have a flood of them in the
nation and then just recently Governor
sununu has pointed out that we now have
an influx coming from Canada so some
those folks are going somewhere those
folks need to live somewhere I'm just
curious about the crowding out effect
of of our Pro on our programs because
this this may be actually a huge budget
requirement that we're not seeing if
we're only looking at funding programs
for these accepted categories
do you follow me
I do and I don't believe there's a
simple answer to your question right or
your concerned I think it's a it's
probably bigger than right uh I like
your big questions yes you do
um I think that
um you know I can certainly provide
information about the number of
individuals who we are serving currently
through the refugee program I can't tell
you the number of them that are illegal
versus legal but I can try to look into
that information and talk show my
mistake and I thought Refugee was a word
for those invited you know like the
people from Afghanistan the people from
uh Ukraine you know we we've we've
invited particular people to come to our
nation as refugees
does that term include those that we've
not explicitly invited I'm not sure that
I would use the word invited there is
looking for a polite word to say this
because there's an extensive process
that the U.S Department of State
conducts when accepting or not
individuals who would be who would come
to the United States as a refugee
there's significant screening uh this
takes weeks to conduct before they are
before they enter into the United States
services in any of those states have to
be coordinated and agreed upon
wherever the destination may be so we
have services available in New Hampshire
that do provide act as that point
organization if you will for those
particular individuals to then provide
them with appropriate or necessary
Community Services which are very
temporary
um
so again I can't give you a specific
answer on the number of individuals who
um
come here to to the state I can tell you
that I can get you a number of the
individuals we have provided Refugee
services to all right and just to come
back to why I'm asking these questions
is because we have pre-established needs
for these programs and we have a new
surge of people who can be showing up in
New Hampshire
placing demands on an already scarce
resource right and I'm just curious what
the impact of that's going to be in
terms of us trying to if we wanted as a
policy issue just support those folks or
what the budget impact might be and what
the policy issue might be if we want to
continue to prioritize New Hampshire
citizens
so
so so so we can we can come off of this
and have this discussion later but but
uh representative hole and then I think
representative Wallner
thank you Mr chair and I'm not sure who
the right person is to address the
question to
um I spent a year working in a
non-profit drug and alcohol rehab during
that time I learned a lot about
um mental health and and addictions and
how to treat it I also found out that
you can only help people who want to be
helped at the bottom line you can't
force someone to want to get help
it doesn't work you spend you can spend
all the money and time in the world if
they don't want to get better they can't
so the question is is what is in the
current program to help filter out to
focus the resources on those who want to
get better broadly speaking
in the context of your question I think
director Fox would probably be best to
answer
foreign
so we have a hot potato going back and
forth between the two of us so be happy
to try to address that I agree I
understand
um especially with your experience where
you're coming from
um what I think it's incumbent upon all
of us is to offer the opportunity and
perhaps
um more than once but that we don't
expect there's no mandate there's no
expectation that someone has to be in a
particular program so we offer the
opportunity we leave doors open but we
don't
um we don't interfere with someone's
right to be able to
not engage right but is there
thank you is there a point right I agree
leaving the door open right you want to
make sure the help is available but
there is a point where someone is
choosing not to take advantage of that
and continuing to make sure those
resources are available to that person
versus someone who is saying hey I want
to get better I want to I I want I want
to overcome this I want to change my
lifestyle
is there anything we can do to help
focus on those who want to get ahead
because there's a huge return putting
those people back into society's
productive citizens
so I think that we already unfortunately
do that we prioritize by the fact that
we have limited resources and so for
those who who do want to engage we do
provide those services for those who
don't we we just don't have the
opportunity to expend as much on trying
to convince them on in our ways you know
that like so I think it's a balance I
think that some people reach a point
much later than we would want them to
reach that so that that door is open
when they are willing and able to take
advantage of services
so I think this is relevant to this
dialogue here but a few years ago I was
on the board of a transitional housing
charity and uh one of the issues that
confronted that transitional housing
organization is that the federal
government had something I think it was
called housing first and so if you
brought somebody into your uh
congregate housing situation and and one
of them continued to abuse drugs even
Supply drugs in some instances that they
had to remain in the congregate living
situation without the ability of the
organization to remove them because that
Federal housing first program
um
organizations that chose not to accept
the housing first program were
prohibited from getting any federal
money
so I'm I'm kind of curious to
representative holes in general question
is to what extent is the federal housing
first
requirements still in effect is it
causing us issues with being selective
and prioritizing people who really want
help
is it tying our hands or is there a
waiver that we ought to be asking for
any of those things
so this is one of those areas where I am
going to plead ignorance and say that
I'll have to get back to you with a
response to that since I do know that a
housing first exists but I don't know
the details of the requirements
when that model is employed so I'm going
to have to get back to you on that
that's very fair representative walner
yes thank you in the area of
homelessness
um
what are
are there I'm sure there are many gaps
in the services that we provide
and the need
and I wondered is was there a
prioritized need a request that was not
funded in this budget
yes
um so we have our shelter programs that
currently receive eight dollars a day
per bed you know per um utilization and
we had uh proposed to increase that to
twenty dollars and to expand capacity
um by not a great amount but by a little
bit and that was to the tune of 10
million dollars for the shelter programs
and an additional so it was a an
additional 2 million for some of those
Support Services
um for those individuals in
stabilization so yes we had uh 12
million dollars in a prioritized need
request each each of the fiscal years
and there currently is a bill in the
Senate that would provide the majority
of that funding
SB 231 I believe
so so this question has been asked a few
times and every time it gets asked I
mean just to request if it hasn't
already been provided sort of a
Consolidated list of all the prioritized
needs that didn't get satisfied by the
governor as far as I know we already
have that from you and I just don't know
where it is
so so I've been accumulating a list of
change requests and then prioritize
needs from each discussion my plan was
once we finish all the presentations to
provide that listing to you unless you'd
like it piecemeal
I don't know how I want it I just know
that we're going to end up getting
feeling like we're crushed for time and
as soon as we get uh hb2 over to us I'm
probably going to ask Mr Ripple and uh
representative nordgren to help me
figure out how we could begin to vote on
some of the components of the budget to
kind of move them along and get them out
of the way and I don't know that we
could do that without good visibility on
the prioritized needs yeah so I I was
planning a high level summary document
that would have the individual change
requests the prioritized needs and then
a separate I Was preparing a layman's
term document for the hb2 provisions to
try to translate sometimes it's the
language that's included in hb2 is not
intuitive whatsoever to provide that to
the committee as well so that when you
look at the hb2 provision and it's
citing some chapter law from three years
ago there's an explanation behind that
so it's clear to the committee what that
is to help you move forward with your
votes okay I don't I don't want to ask
you to do a thrashing exercise where
you're constantly updating it because
we'll just lose track of it anyways and
it's not worth the overhead okay so so
just know that I'm really glad you're
going to provide that because I think we
have real utility for it and or it has
really utility and sooner is better than
later obviously
do you understand what I'm saying
representative nordgren about trying to
foreign
right but the other part I want to just
check with you on is is what I'm hoping
to do is when we get our hb2 and uh and
we've got several of these uh budgets
that we've gone over that we uh start
our voting early to remove the things
that we all agree on uh the the the the
low-hanging fruit within the budget so
that we can narrow our Focus where there
might be a little more controversy yeah
so I'll be coming to you in a week or
two asking where where we can begin to
prioritize early voting yes
and then you're obviously the key player
in that
okay all right so
um do you know where we left off yeah
is there additional
I think we're down to a page or two yeah
and I'm assuming that when we hit the
end of the colored coloring book that
we're we're done with you right
so um we I think we're on 31 is that
correct yes yes we're on 31. so this um
goes into more detail about the
Continuum of Care
um and how that's designed at the
continued of care brings together a
bunch of individuals at a community
level so there may be a lead but it's
really Community Driven and planned so
that there's improved coordination and
integration and identifying those
prioritized needs as we go through not
in the same way that we use them here at
the finance table
um and then the funding as I said that
it's not a lot of dollars when you look
at the amount of need and actually the
amount of work that's done
page 32 again just a geographic
distribution and depiction of how that
balance of State works
I'm looking at your map and around
Nashua it's it's it's a darker color yes
what does
it says is that just to indicate that
that's the greater Nashua area and yeah
and why why do we care about Nashua and
Manchester is that because that's where
the federal programs are yes yes so when
the federal government through
um HUD makes those Awards there are
three designated uh continuums of care
and that is a direct
um relationship between Manchester and
greater Nashua with HUD and then we have
the direct relationship with the balance
estate all right thank you
and then the key accomplishments
um there's a good list there
um there has been the coordinated entry
process
um so that there is an opportunity to
see
um when someone comes in there's that
assessment that's done and standardize
the way that people are assessed and
referred
um and then the other accomplishments
include the grants anytime we receive a
grant that's above and beyond the
traditional funding that we've had is a
victory and a reason to celebrate so
we've had rapid re-housing for
individuals talking about prioritized
needs and prioritized populations so
survivors of domestic violence and human
trafficking so those two projects
and then let me ask you about the human
trafficking part of this yep the other
day we we heard that there were about 12
people that we had identified in the
previous calendar year as being victims
of of trafficking that they tended to be
all New Hampshire people and they all
seem to be correlated heavily with uh
with drug use probably to keep the
person from being competent enough to
leave on their own but so so what are
what are we doing in the in a human
trafficking area if they're we're
talking about 12 people
so that was 12 identified in that
particular year there are others that
have been identified previous to so it's
a cumulative you know what I mean so we
had 12 that were identified in that
fiscal year human trafficking I'm not
sure what part of our department
addresses that and works most closely on
that this program was just awarded so it
has yet to um to be implemented
okay but I assume that they it's
transitional also that it's it's not
meant to
keep keep them perpetually dependent on
the state correct all right
representative
thank you Mr chair
there are a number of non-profit
groups kind of sex trafficking survivors
broadly speaking within the state
um
some of whom are on the speaking circuit
some of whom are available for
consultation I think the numbers are
unfortunately the number is far greater
than 12 in the state that's where the
problem is have you guys consulted with
them to to work with where where they
either the touch points are here's where
the person is is most likely to be
receptive to help
or here's the here's the underlying
circumstances or the um
The Good the indicators that are really
if you spot this this is also going on
type thing
I don't know how to broadcast I'm not
going to ask that question but the key
indicators that's probably the better
term right
and and and talked with those that are
coming unfortunately out of this
horrific lifestyle
so I know that the Attorney General's
office has played a prominent role in
addressing this issue not just in the
prosecution but also in the programming
for those individuals so and there may
be areas of our department that I am not
aware of that are working specifically
on this issue so again it's one of those
I can come back with to you with that
okay so
um Karen was just
um saying that when we have the balance
estate when I said we bring together all
those groups and representatives there
are representatives from this particular
population and Advocates um people who
Advocate on behalf of them
and just the last point that I'll make
is that housing and this issue crosses a
lot of departments in the state as I
mentioned before we have the Community
Development Finance Authority New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority and
others who all serve on the um the
Council on housing stability and that is
a very representative group of counties
providers
and state Personnel who serve on that
and we have recommendations can get the
report to you if if you haven't seen it
our associate commissioner Chris
Antonello is one of the co-chairs of
that and can provide we can provide more
information on that but that's really
where we come together and try to solve
the the issues and some of the
legislation that you've seen in the past
couple years has been a direct result of
the recommendations from that Council
I am done you know um it's not in here
but I would just you know my one of my
takeaways on one of your your key
challenges is you have
um there are so many social determinants
of care
there are so many organizations involved
there are so many Community Resources
out there
that there's not an information system
to create a common uh view of the
situation and what and who's doing what
and where and so to me it feels like you
have like a tremendous coordination
challenge
without any tools to support efficient
Communications and coordination and and
so
so I don't know how you do it I don't
know how you do it without just like
pulling your hair out to try to keep
track of all the moving Parts in that
thing so so I I don't know if I've heard
something you've not brought into the
record but that would be one of my
concerns is how do we how do we give you
the tools to make that job easier or do
we need to
yeah and I think you've raised the point
that we have multiple tools but they
don't necessarily all coordinate
um together so we we do have
um a homeless management information
system that is for is for specifically
for
um this this Bureau but then we have
other systems across the board so yeah
it's something that we want to bring in
and I think you've heard Dave Wieters
talk about those efforts
um and I think um you heard Trish Tilly
talk a little bit about that bringing
that data together and information
together and it's something that if we
had one solution it would be great but I
think that it's a system all of those
systems have been built in their legacy
systems and then there's the Homegrown
and there's the
um the different programs and Excel
sheets and all of that and and yeah it's
something we have worked on and we
appreciate your interest because it's
helped Propel us to be able to focus on
that and frankly get some support on it
um as a follow-up to our discussions
yesterday Mr White has done a great job
going through and very knowledgeable I
guess at some point
will he be available to do kind of a
line by line Page by Page to go through
the 100 plus pages of the budget can we
schedule that I mean at the at the hb1
level just because there's a bunch of
questions that are in the nitty-gritty
in terms of funding accounts and
as a new member of the committee there's
a bunch of background information I
don't have but Mr White might have
so let me say this about that
um
we we have a Time budget uh you have an
information requirement one of the ways
I was hoping to create space for that
was to work with uh representative
nordgren and you all to identify where
we can move issues off of our plate
sooner so that we can narrow our focus
and to the extent that we have ongoing
questions I I think I think we still
have what uh Mr Ripple about 10 days
that we've reserved for work sessions
that are not yet programmed for activity
foreign
that's true I'm hoping you can get
through all the presentations by the end
of next week I'm not sure if that'll be
possible there may be a straggler that
goes into the week after but you will
have about a week and a half uh in which
to make decisions
so so thank you so one of the things
that uh representative Mooney has been
doing is she's been pinging you everyone
to say okay we just heard about this
what are your questions what are your
issues and I I would hope to the extent
that you've gone through these and you
go oh look here's here's several areas
that I don't think I have enough data
that you're sending that to her so that
we have some mapping of what your your
information need is
any other comments for our guests I'll
go out to the audience and say is there
anyone who came here wanting to say
something or has been triggered to want
to say something that would like to say
something
seeing any motion
go ahead come on up
yeah come to the microphone because
you're you're live
and then you'll want to read the name so
uh representative Stringham knows you if
you've got a business card that's even
more better
um Jim Monahan with the DuPont group um
and we did
um uh we do have two representatives in
the community community mental health
centers here today uh that we're hoping
to explain uh to the committee the memo
that we had sent you previously with
regard to a wage Gap and housing issues
okay so I now I just need to figure out
how much time they need and whether or
not we should take a short break for
lunch or just uh drive through so what
what kind of time do you think we we
need
for the the
time 10 minutes maybe 10 minutes yeah
does anyone object to us going to 12 30
and and trying to wrap up
okay all right
okay
this is
and the same thing if you all have
business cards to drop off we'll we'll
take them
uh so I'm gonna let um Maggie perch it
in and Jonathan with your introduce
themselves some rolled safe play but
just to orient the committee the
information provided to you includes a
fancy annual report which details the
work of the Community Mental Health
Centers but more specifically there's a
budget memo
um included in there which addresses
issues with regard to vacancies at the
community mental health centers and then
offers uh perspective on the workforce
challenges that that we're facing as
well as touches on some specific needs
and requests with regard to housing for
the mental health community so I'm going
to hand it off I guess to
um Maggie Pritchard to start
I promise I'll talk very fast
um my name is Maggie Pritchard I'm the
CEO for the Lakes Region Mental Health
Center which covers Plymouth and some of
Grafton County
um and I worked 40 years in Community
Mental Health starting in Manchester
Nashua Dover I've been around with the
block a couple of times right now I
serve as the president of the community
Behavioral Health Association and the
reason we're here today is because the
Medicaid rates are determined by you
right to some extent and so I can't say
like Walmart I want to raise the price
of my pencil so that I can pay my
employees more right or because my
health insurance cost went up I'm
beholden to the system because we serve
at the Community Mental Health Center
the most vulnerable and the poorest
citizens of our state and so therefore
when the Medicaid rates don't change or
don't keep time with the cost of living
and other things our employees start to
fade away and go away and we lose them
and they don't come back because they
take jobs that pay more and we're trying
to fix this Workforce issue from a
number of areas from student loan
repayment programs to internships You
Name It We Do It retention bonuses
sign-on bonuses although we can't
compete with some of the for-profit
agencies that offer sign-on bonuses so
right now we're coming to you because we
believe that our Workforce is in
desperate need
so so miss Pritchard thank you for
coming
um I I want to I want to give you some
context in case you hadn't heard from
our other hearings on this subject where
I think we're at as a as a Division I I
think we're where we're at and then if
if you all want to correct me but uh
I'll I'll take that but where I think
we're at is that
um in the governor's budget proposal
with the 3.1 percent across the board
Medicaid rate he invited us to take a
more targeted approach uh in previous
years
advocates for a particular segment of
our health care System have had some
success at coming in individually ass
justifying a particular increase in
their area for which we've put a
Band-Aid on a lot of those
we've gone long enough that when talking
to Mr lippman
it sounds like the time has has come
where we need as sort of a an entire
fresh look at rate setting across the
board
and in an Ideal World
your particular request would be in the
context of a big picture
assessment of where we are on rates
across the Medicaid Spectrum okay but
it's not a perfect world that rate
setting process
is going to take at best six months
probably you know more like a year I'm
kind of hoping that it'll get done
before the next budget process starts
you know to be frank with you but um but
so what I also what we've also said to
Mr Lipman is look that's a long time and
there are things that are getting ready
to break that we don't want broken so so
so reach in
to the rate setting problem and help us
identify those areas where there's the
most critical need so that we can we can
slap another Band-Aid or two potentially
knowing that it's a sub-optimal way for
us to do our job right and so so you're
here with a valid request I'm absolutely
convinced that you are
that my Challenge and maybe the
challenge that's shared by the other
members is how do we look at your very
valid request
in isolation given that we know that we
have probably a much bigger structural
deficit over years of sort of neglect in
the Medicaid reimbursement rates and and
and
so I just want to share that with you so
that as you continue to speak to us that
maybe you could help us walk through
what I think we need to also be hearing
is
um what what what is the case for
looking at your area in isolation of the
bigger problem uh is there something on
the verge of collapse or breaking that
is would be hard to restore I mean we're
sort of in a crisis management moment
here can can you help us yeah so I would
say the biggest issue or the biggest
problem is that not putting at least a
Band-Aid on Mental Health means that you
will see expense in other places right
so when I have 50 people lined up at the
door who want treatment and as
representative house said you got to
work with people when they want and when
they can change I can't take them in the
door because I don't have any staff to
treat them right and so what happens is
people become more ill it's sort of like
if you can't get a haircut and your hair
gets out of control you're going to be
out of control until you get a haircut
and what happens with mental illness is
you don't treat them you have people
stand in line you make them wait they
don't get better there's not a way to
get better and so as somebody who's
responsible for the financial stability
of our state I would say that investing
in something that's going to save you
money and save people's lives is is a
good thing right but I'm not going to
tell you that children and old people
who need In-Home Care are any less
worthy of those dollars and those
Medicaid funds I can't I can't sit here
and do that that wouldn't be fair right
I can just tell you that running a
mental health center and working in one
for the last 40 years that I can't get
people to come and work for me and that
makes me very anxious about what's at
risk in my community who's at risk right
I have 22 vacancies right now 21 of them
are for bachelor's level and Master's
level clinicians
okay so
um
so right now the Urgent issue that we
have is this court order where we have
people who are warehoused and it's
people who like that term but I think it
works is that we were warehousing people
in emergency rooms because we don't have
room in the New Hampshire hospital
because there's no place in the
communities to move them
so your
a catcher's mitt are you not your
facility receives would be open to being
a
receiver of patients at the New
Hampshire hospital to help us move
people out of there if you had more
capacity is that is that accurate that's
absolutely true so I I don't mean to
boil it down or minimize it I'm just
trying to understand the workflow and
exactly where you fit in and what
problem we're trying to solve
right and when you think about someone
who's inpatient versus someone who's in
community and I'm charged essentially
with prioritizing should I get someone
out because I got to get someone in and
how do I do that balance and and
something has to give in the system we
wouldn't have written this we wouldn't
have gotten on top of it with all of you
and having met with some of you
previously just to say this is really a
crisis right now if you don't fix this
you also have other expenses down the
road that you don't want to pay for
um and so we wanted to make a plea in
particular for mental health not because
they're more deserving of anyone else
but because our system is in a crisis
Jonathan did you want to see it he runs
the biggest Mental Health Center
thank you for the record on Jonathan
ruthier Executive Vice President for the
mental health center of Greater
Manchester and if that's a twist for
some of you you've seen me here
presenting on behalf of the
developmental disability system in my
prior role at cs9 but I joined the
mental health center of Greater
Manchester a little over a year ago
because most of my career has been in
mental health and I really I felt uh
that our our growing problem in being
able to serve people required people who
had experience to come back to the fold
so in addition to my role as a Executive
Vice President and I'm also in the
preparation process to start providing
Services again where I'm able to and
given the the confines of my schedule
um just for context we're you know we
are the largest Mental Health Center in
this state
we serve about 12 000 people a year and
I have 500 families who can't get served
right now uh because of our our lack of
clinicians and that's just in our
children's Department we have a total of
71 open positions 68 of those are
clinical positions and um you know at
least uh
a third of those are our master's level
clinicians
our rapid response team you've heard a
lot about rapid response we have a 55
vacancy rate there so we rely on people
doing overtime and filling in extra
shifts from other departments
and that's great it's a great
opportunity for people to learn that
with those skills and it's a great
opportunity for people to chip in and it
has a shelf life people get tired and
we've our our staff surveys tell us how
tired people are they're exhausted
they're exhausted for paperwork they're
exhausted from uh you know working too
long and having to chip in all over the
place to cover holes I greatly
appreciate your awareness and attention
to this any of us I think would be happy
to answer questions now or or outside of
committee session to help inform your
decision making on this
thank you
um just a comment I think
one of the issues obviously that's
impacted mental health but it all those
services medical hospitals whatever has
been the pandemic and people who are
retiring early
just because they need to get out and
hopefully not get coveted so I think
part of the issue obviously for a lot of
the agencies and I think some of them
have mentioned is that there's a whole
new crowd of younger people that we need
to get engaged
in the system so that they can come in
and try to fill those gaps and obviously
one of the issues would be pay and
trying to recruit
so I think you're just one of the many
organizations that's having the same
problem
across the
Spectrum thank you
I assume you agree with them yeah I
agree I also do a lot of uh speaking at
high schools and trying to get kids
interested and I like to think I could
have been a used car salesman in another
life so maybe I could sell these kids on
being mental health professionals
um but to my dismay not many of them
raise their hand maybe one in a crowd of
30 40 kids and then it's I want to be a
psychiatrist or I want to be something
else but not quite the boots on the
ground person who has to work day to day
with someone who's really struggling
with a mental health issue in their home
or in their community so
representative Waller
I'm just going to ask if you could just
briefly talk about your ask here and
um
you know
how much you're proposing for rate
increase for the Medicaid rate and then
talk a little bit about the housing
support how that would work
um so I'm going to ask you to look at
the chart that's included in terms of
our Research into terms of what we're
paying people right now in our system
and what
other people pay in the system and how
far behind we are in that so we did the
math for you that says you know we'd be
a lot closer if we came up with about 28
million dollars to pay our staff right
um because we're this far off with our
psychiatrists with our nurse
practitioners with our master's level
clinicians
um and so I mean I can give it to Jim in
terms of the housing numbers but I know
that when up my staff quit and I'm
paying them 18 to 21 an hour and they
say go on a Hobby Lobby and I won't have
to work nights or weekends if I don't
have any mandated overtime or anything
so it was very nice working with you and
I'll see you later and I say that's a
darn shame because I really want you to
go on and get your master's degree and
do more for this population and work
with us a lot longer I can't do that if
I'm not paying them a livable wage right
and I'm asking a lot of them
so I have two questions for you about
the 28 million number what
what is that in terms of a percentage
increase and then how did you arrive at
28 million was that like a one of those
disciplined Personnel pay scale analyzes
or is that due to your experience and
judgment
that's a pay scale analysis
yeah
um so and I apologize the author of the
uh the study was not available to be
here today but we can bring it back if
you want but um yes it was
uh uh
a pay scale analysis if that's the term
used well we took a look at
um across the 10 Community Mental Health
Centers in these clinical disciplines
what the what the the wage scale look
like and then compared it to those to
the Bureau of Labor Statistics and then
when we analyze the differential we'd
applied it over the number of positions
that we have so that's where we came up
with the uh 28 million now that's in the
context of uh
um annual spend of about 120 million
dollars a year in the Medicaid Program
to the Community Mental Health Centers
so it's a 16 18
um increase okay
um and then the other question is I I
see what you're trying to do with pay
I think our lever is Medicaid
reimbursement rates though
um and and so do you have specific CPT
codes that you think we ought to focus
on and do you have a recommendation more
at the procedure code level is that the
right question representative Stringham
I'm I'm I'm dancing on your area well
you know I saw you had OCC codes and I
was wondering if you're paid based on
hourly uh and whether the rates are set
by these OCC codes when you come up with
uh mean hourly wages and I mean I would
think that's probably where you were
going if you wrote it this way
so
if you could provide any tutorial on how
your your fee schedule is set up
um because you know certainly in here we
see there there's some OCC codes that uh
it looks like you're paid over cost in
one category and and some of the other
ones are quite severely in the other
direction
so it would seem to indicate that if if
we can adjust by the OCC code we may
want to emphasize some of them in
changing the rates over others I'm not
familiar with the term OCC what is an
OCC
relative to a CPT uh
is it
occupation code yes yeah that's the
Bureau of Statistics versus the I
believe right the Imperial decision
versus the American Metal coding you're
talking about is the health care
Coatings but if but if it would be
helpful the you may or may not be aware
of it there was a significant reform
five years ago where the Community
Mental Health Centers moved away from a
fee-for-service system we now have a
system where the centers take risk and
they get paid on a per member per month
basis
um and I think
um with regards to your question about
these how these
rates translate into wages
um I think it's a now okay
my my question isn't on that because I
can't directly affect your wages so we
we have a lever we can change a
reimbursement rate and hope that that
triggering of that reimbursement rate
change gives you the capacity to change
your own wages we're not we're not
managing wages we're managing
reimbursement rates I believe does
anyone disagree with that
that's what it sounds like because it's
a capitated model so you get paid
um I know you know you may have more
than one category for Peak how many four
four separate categories and there's a
rate for each one of them
and uh so
um what would be
more actionable on our side is probably
understand
um uh which of those uh whether whether
those all all four are under under
reimbursed or under the fee schedule is
too low universally or whether there's
some that's end up resulting in critical
shortages because they require a lot
more
clinical and counseling psychologists
which are you know 45 percent underpaid
right now I guess according to your
system so
yeah I was just gonna uh thank you for
the for the question and the follow-up
commentary uh the four categories are
are all the eligibility categories under
our state rules for eligibility for
services that's not the same as the CPT
codes that representative Edwards is is
uh asking about and I don't know that
our analysis here really fleshes out
which of those areas of the fee schedule
would need to be addressed specifically
in order to uh you know to to make sure
that the
types of services are receiving the
right reimbursement so you know we've
sort of basically asked at this point on
sort of the Gap that we have and and
um I'm assuming we're working with uh
Henry Litman in the Medicaid office to
see you know how does that actually
break out in terms of the underlying fee
schedule that is used to determine the
rates for
of payment under the capitated model
so what we're struggling with is my
ignorance uh because I I just need to
make sure I understand
what would what a an hb2 item would look
like are would we be increasing
potentially these these four occs or
would we that's what it's sounding to me
an example
um to all the committee members of some
targeted rate increases that were done
back in 2017 to give you an idea of what
that looked like that did not reference
specific codes it referenced specific
types of services and providers so that
might be something you'd like to
consider instead
well since 2017 I've heard that maybe
their their fee structures have moved
away from fee for schedule to a
capitated rate and so I don't know if
the 2017 example matches what our
current situation is I I just it's I
literally don't know
I'm not sure either but I think that's
something I could look into for you
okay and
maybe we could give Mr Lemon also to be
looking at it because I think he's
working on a homework I'm I'm talking
past you to Mr White he because he's
looking at sort of the crisis fixes and
and so so he could help us with this
right
all right so we can certainly be uh
responsive to that I think that you know
as I've seen it uh dealt with in the
budget before it's uh it's done through
a combination of appropriation that is
then footnoted with instructions to the
department for how to uh allocate or
spend the funds that that would be very
useful and I'm not promising that we'll
add anything to it I'm just looking for
what the vehicle would look like if the
committee chose to do that was happy to
provide the road map to success all
right so go ahead representative moving
beyond I guess the four categories of
eligibility for services separately talk
about residential housing support and
that sounds like a pretty separate
category and your recommendation or or
request there is uh to raise the rate
um to from 232 79 to between 265 and 374
a day so so that would be a range of
13.9 percent
um you know presumably over the two
years to sixty percent is that correct
and is there anything else that you want
to
um
you know to help us understand the need
and uh what we get from that
thanks uh yeah you've correctly
identified the ass there
um and in addition to that
um in order to help offset the capital
costs associated with that we've also
asked for a one-time
appropriation of 1.5 million dollars to
uh fund sick to contribute twenty five
thousand dollars towards
for each per bed but I think um maybe
um Maggie pritch's best to answer the
the housing need issue
all right I'm gonna date myself now so
um the two the two 3279 rate that we
currently get for housing is for
Community residents so that means it's a
person living in 24-hour care there's
someone on site with them
the rate at one point was so low most
centers walked away from being able to
provide 24-hour care because they
couldn't cover their cost you'd have to
have like 50 people living in the place
in order to break even right with the
rate that you were getting we're trying
to get back to a place where we
recognize the need that people have for
24-Hour care but we also recognize the
expense of 24-hour care and so at 232 a
day if you have 10 adults that
participate and follow all the federal
rules and state rules that are required
for a community residence you can
probably afford to do that right you
might even be able to afford it six or
seven
um and so we want to make sure that that
rate covers the cost because the night
shift is very hard to cover I will tell
you that right now no one wants to be
awake overnight and nobody wants to be
doing this kind of care so that rate in
particular is for those people who need
24-hour care that we are seeing many of
them fall through gaps not being able to
make it in the community because there
isn't 24-hour care available and there
could be less available if we don't do
something about that rate
are you familiar with HP 527 if you've
seen it or looked at it heard about it
I'm sure Susan gave it to me but I don't
because because this sounds similar and
I and I and again I I'm just addressing
a gap in my knowledge of whether or not
the requests that you you all may be
advancing would simultaneously be
hitting the same Target that HP 527 was
intended to hit Yes mine is saying if HP
527 was it was addressing a specific
class of long-term care assisted living
facilities
um in asking for a carve out for an
additional reimbursement level for that
this is different than that because it's
not the long-term care population and
we're not asking for a carve out for a
particular subset of housing we're
asking for a cost adjustment to the
to the per diem rate that's paid to all
providers in the same class
so the it's the all provider thing that
I'm I'm wondering is is if is is if
we're as we're if if to the extent that
we try to come up with a partial
solution to your problem
because of of trying to solve your
problem Are we simultaneously solving
some of the problems of 527 I see you
saying no representative
totally different group yep and that
five times they operate under a separate
waiver oh okay that answers my question
uh who
for example in an amendment to House
Bill 527 it says specifically that it
would be applicable to those uh who are
licensed under administrative rule he
hyphen p804
my guess is that is not you thank you
all right I I'm out of questions are
there any other further questions from
the committee
just say a word about the about the
capital
appropriation that you have here
you wanted to I mean it's twenty five
thousand dollars per bed uh yeah new bed
yep and I'm I guess
um that certainly would not cover the
cost it was based upon and I have to go
back and do the math but I think it was
on trying to stand up 60 beds
um at a close to 25
000 uh the average
five in a group setting would be five
individuals so that the actual Capital
cost about 75 000 per bed so we're
asking for a third of that as I hope I
hope offset that costs
to be honest if the folks from Seacoast
mental health were here they'd say I
can't buy anything for 450 000
yeah
uh and then just uh backing into the you
know the 28 million dollar figure uh
this included here that is total fund
total funds
um and um uh so the general fund portion
of it would be approximately 45 of that
yeah
all right so I'm not seeing any more
questions for from the committee you're
you're satisfied that you know what you
need to know at this point I just just
so the committee knows and and and those
in the audience
um representative Stringham in his uh
real world life uh deals a lot with
Medicare uh reimbursable issues and so
uh I've asked him to kind of take point
or take the lead for division three and
trying to help us understand and
navigate you know these critical fixes
that we have to Prior or consider
prioritizing so
um so I know what I don't know and I
don't know what he knows so so I'm
asking and I hope you're still
comfortable with that that you can take
the continue to take the lead for the
division to chart understand and
contextualize this well I don't I don't
know if I can take the lead because you
know you've seen one fee schedule you've
seen one fee schedule and um I've seen
one
so um but but it is interesting
um to to draw a reference to the other
fee schedules I've worked with and but I
still uh need everybody else's help here
too what what's logical and
um just one person so
but thank you for the kind words
all right so um your your excuse thank
you for coming I did you get a chance to
say everything you intended to say
okay
oh okay very good uh anyone else in the
uh audience
Dr Dr hen I now I have to start calling
you Dr hen
no okay all right
um so so I'm gonna close the hearing but
I'm going to take another 60 seconds
with the division so that closes our
work session uh today
um then for
the committee I I I think that the next
time we're supposed to get together is
uh is next week it's the 27th right
Monday the 27th no no this I still have
February I need a mark
it is the next meeting date that's been
scheduled is Monday the 6th and you have
a full committee meeting in the morning
and a division meeting in the afternoon
to address bills
um you'll also have more agency
presentations on Tuesday and Wednesday
that will be scheduled today and I did
have one question for you
um I was wondering if you would be
willing to meet for the final
presentation on Tuesday the
that'd be the 13th the 14th
um
that is town meeting day and in the past
members have been reluctant to meet on
town meeting day so I was wondering what
you thought about that
town meeting day in Auburn tends to be
in the morning
so so it's not the whole day that would
be problematic in my scenario it would
just be the morning does anyone
have a I have a problem with some of you
are like moderators and stuff who you
got to be there I'm an artist's evening
I'm just I believe it's 6 p.m so as long
as I can get up at 5 30.
oh
okay so so just it's generally yes I'll
give everyone a chance to go back and
look at their town meeting uh
obligations and let you know if there's
a crisis okay that may be the only way
to get in one of the divisions that had
to be postponed from an earlier date
they're the division that didn't want us
to meet with them probably
no no they're originally going to be
scheduled for Monday but you have the
full committee and bills online
all right
um
well great and then let's not forget
that Friday it's still possible I think
to jump on a sununu center tour at 8 30
over at the sununu center uh you only
have three people who've said yes from
the whole committee right there are four
members and possibly a guest of
Representative Stringham I'm not sure
yet so that leaves uh three three to
five slots available for other members
if anybody else wants to attend all
right so just let Mr Ripple know
um
I'm not seeing or I do we have something
else
yeah
I you all have received the uh Monday
afternoon work schedule we're looking at
four house bills 565 91 282 614. those
those are all noticed
all right
I am ready to close all of this
so thank you
no one got hurt